I want to revisit the conversation with
a clip from this past weekend of a
Cornell professor expressing the
exhileration he says he felt after that
attack happened let's roll
that
[Music]
theas
hasur the illusion of
disability there many
dos of Good Will many Palestinians
cous who have
violence as you as who have the
targeting of civilians as do you as do
I who were able to
breathe they were able to
breathe the first time in
years it was exhilerating
it was
ex challenge to the Monopoly of Violence
by this shifting of
theol
[Music]
would
[Applause]
[Music]
first let me just say that I hear
complaints that harping on the stuff
from left Lefty activists and professors
is not as important as what's happening
in Israel and Gaza and that is
absolutely true but the reason I think
it's worth talking about is because it's
a real maskoff moment for the social
justice left that they use all these
academic terms decolonialization
Shifting the power Dynamic but we are
now seeing in practice what all of that
means it means we're okay with killing
innocent people non-combatants maybe we
won't do it ourselves maybe we'll throat
clear before but we'll excuse it just
like how we excused the Looting and
destruction in the summer of 2020 with
this outof context MLK quote about riots
as the voice of the unheard
and it's just been years of
microaggression silence is violence
punch fascists and fascists is like
everyone to the right of Hugo Chavez
that's what I hear with this rhetoric
you're giving permission to cheer
Slaughter and as long as you're on the
wrong side of the simplistic oppressor
oppressed dichotomy we're going to shrug
at best when it happens and you know you
can criticize Israel's government all
you want and they they should be
criticized I've criticized them some
today but you don't make excuses for
barbaric killing because you agree with
the cause and it's just asking for
something really ugly to happen in this
country and when it does part of that is
going to be on people like that guy
you're supposed to be an intellectual
role model so start acting like
it yeah I mean my thoughts on this are a
very strong and concise that guy um
there is no excuse for that type of
thing nothing about watching innocent
people be murder murdered was
exhilarating nothing about that was
exciting it was Despicable it was a
horrible unprovoked senseless act of
violence and it's really stunning to me
that people all across college campuses
sometimes at very elite schools you know
we have this happening at Cornell we
have this happening at Harvard uh we
have this happening at the University of
Pennsylvania the degree to which the
left has consistently um you know the
far-left the progressive woke campus
activists and academics have really
shown themselves to be simplistic in
their understandings of foreign policy
uh simplistic in their understandings of
race relations simplistic in sort of
promulgating their colonizer narratives
acting as if you know basically the
racial Dynamics and colonist dynamics of
the United States can be mapped on to
every other area in the world which is
obviously patently false I mean for
about N9 years now these same people
have been shouting about microaggression
and the need for safe spaces and
shouting down campus speakers um in one
case I remember I think it was the
middleberry college case where they
ended up also like assaulting a a uh the
person it was the Charles Murray Allison
Stanger talk they ended up assaulting
Allison uh who by the way was the sort
of slightly more Lefty person presented
as the foil the person there to
challenge Charles Murray um so you
literally in some cases have these
campus uh speaker shout Downs that are
resulting in actual violence and yet
these are the same people who want to
act like the littlest thing is a
microaggression I'm sorry this is a
macroaggression you don't get to
stand on stage and you know talk about
how exhilarating it is to see people be
brutally raped and murdered uh it's it's
I I wonder whether this will be the
moment that the radical campus and
academic left breaks it feels like the
cracks have been forming it feels like
some of the grift and Corruption present
in the black lives matter organization
and the higher ups like Patrice kers it
seems like people have really lost some
faith in that um we also saw a lot of
sort of Hamas paraglider graphic design
uh co-opting by BLM and by DSA groups in
the US I wonder whether DSA black lives
matter and some of these woke campus
groups will sort of completely lose
credibility forever because of this
moment I think it's very possible I mean
it's already becoming a liability
because employer ERS are trying to ask
if you are affiliated with this group or
that group that did that and you know
I'm not someone who is for that kind of
oppressive we might call cancel culture
uh but the to the degree that it does
become a
liability I think that that there's an
there's there's enough of a backlash
where we we might start to see a little
bit of that unwind but whether it does
or not I mean it we need people stand
against that and call that crap out
because we have to defend like the
liberal Society we have to defend the
idea that it's not acceptable to violate
people's rights and their life and their
property just because they happen to be
in a disfavored group that's just like a
fundamental Bedrock of what this whole
thing is supposed to be about and these
people it it's reached a Breaking Point
for me at least uh with this like that
um they are eroding that just really
fundamental bedrock and by the way his
assertion that uh oh it's so exciting
exhilarating to see this power Dynamic
flip
like flipped I mean uh Israel is uh
annihilating Hamas and the Gaza Strip is
never going to be the same after like
there there hasn't been some sort of
like amazing shift in power like we
learned talking to Max Abrams last week
terrorist attacks like this they don't
achieve their political objective and
the hamas's political objective is not
to help the people in Gaza or the West
Bank at least in the short term it's to
bolster their image and put them at the
center of some bigger movement and
they'll they'll rack up as much
collateral damage as they need to to do
so so this this is a really just
disappointing and frustrating moment I
honestly feel like this is the second
installment of the summer of George
Floyd like do you remember that moment
in 2020 after George Floyd was brutally
killed by cops and we're Libertarians we
completely uh reject the fact that so
much police abusive power exists and
that type of thing is is absolutely
horrific to watch um you know reasons
Billy Bion and C.J camela have done
excellent reporting on this but right
after that happened there were all of
those crazy
protests some of which were protests a
lot of them were riots uh and you
remember I mean it's it's now an
internet meme uh the idea of the mostly
peaceful protest and it was like you
know some anchor talking about this as
you know fires were burning in the
background right behind him right like
these were riots and there was enormous
uh property destruction uh that resulted
from this and on one hand you could say
people have every right to to protest
this horrific police killing uh but they
uh ended up really savaging American
cities I mean it was awful you had shop
Windows being boarded up uh as if that's
the sign of a functioning healthy
democracy it was really sad and I think
for a lot of people it was this moment
where there was like a oh this isn't
just advocating for police reform this
isn't just advocating for you know
specific changes to qualified immunity
right like this is people engaging in
these really brutal and sometimes
violent methods of trying to get what
they want Poli
um from the left and like that's not
something that we like they sort of
showed themselves a little bit and I
wonder whether we're currently seeing
this in this current moment where
there's an awful lot of I think
legitimate anti-Semitism coming out and
um a sense that I'm getting from some
far-left Progressive activists that they
authentically think that you know for
people who they consider to be oppress
it is perfectly okay to use violence to
achieve the ends that they desire and I
disagree with that and I think many
normal people on the left disagree with
that I I I wonder what will happen uh
and whether these Progressive far-
leftist ideals and talking points and
groups will continue to exist for years
to come or whether they will just lose
credibility on mass as a result of this
well and I hope that they realize the
degree to which they are tainting these
conversations and the ability to have to
advocate for police reform which is
necessary none none of us thought it was
okay for Derek schin to kneel on this
guy until he died and I'm glad that this
this man is in prison and I continue to
be a believer in an advocate for
Criminal Justice Reform and and police
being held accountable for their actions
and people not being sentenced to
decades and decades in prison uh what
they shouldn't be and similarly I have
sympathy for aspects of the Palestinian
C it's partly why I wanted to have TR on
here today to try to flesh that out a
little bit and explain a little bit of
the the history and the Grievances I
think it's not completely without Merit
but when you are embracing or you know
elevating this iconography it it taints
the conversation and it it just makes it
that much harder to to make any progress
on these issues hey thanks for watching
that clip from our conversation with Tre
parsey about whether the US can and
should deescalate things in the Middle
East you can watch another clip right
here or the full conversation over here